Studies have suggested that we spend as much as half of our hours awake lost in a daydream.
A computer model recently revealed some pretty interesting things...
...about what's happening when we're mentally a million miles away.
For one, parts of the brain shut off.
While it often has to pick between its analytic and empathetic modes,...
...which one is employed is usually determined by the task at hand.
Daydreaming, on the other hand, allows the brain to cycle on its own...
...and eventually both the analytic and empathetic aspects are disengaged.
The brain also determines the structure of the mental getaways.
While it makes sense to think that daydreams are controlled by our consciousness,...
...it's actually fluctuations in the brain's neural networks.
Another phenomenon about the experience is that waking dreams...
...help people free up previously frozen and tucked away information,...
...paving the way for new associations and possible solutions to problems.
An unfortunate side effect is that upon the return to reality,...
...memories of what was going on prior to departure are often lost.
Oddly, the further we mentally travel in time or space, the more we forget.